Військові 127-ої окремої бригади тероборони завдають удару
по мінометному розрахунку росіян,
які зайшли на українську територію на Харківщині.
Працює танк Т-64, яким бригада забезпечила себе сама.
Трофейний танк. Ми з трофейних працюємо,
нас навчали для кожного танка.
Танки - одне з ключових озброєнь у нинішній війні.
За оцінками української сторони, для звільнення окупованих територій
ЗСУ потрібно від 500 до 700 танків.
Голова правління німецького оборонного концерну Rheinmetall Армін Паперґер
вважає, що потреба навіть вища - 600-800 танків для перемоги над Росією.
За словами Паперґера, Rheinmetall веде перспективні переговори
з Києвом про будівництво заводу на території України.
Такий завод за 200 мільйонів доларів зможе виробляти
до 400 нових танків "Пантера" на рік.
Експерти називають це позитивним сигналом для України:
під час війни знаходяться компанії, готові на довгострокові інвестиції.
Думаю, що на нинішньому етапі йдеться скоріше про економічні причини.
Звісно, є і військові, і політичні компоненти цієї історії,
будівництво заводу має схвалити уряд Німеччини.
Але зараз я бачу це так: є німецька фірма, яка зацікавлена
у будівництві заводу в Україні. Це саме те, що потрібно Києву,
зокрема інвестори, готові будувати навіть під час війни та йти на ризик.
Тож це швидше економічний сигнал.
Експерти наголошують: Rheinmetall - це комерційне підприємство,
орієнтоване на отримання прибутку. І нагадують: до анексії Криму
компанія кілька років будувала центр бойової підготовки
в Нижньогородській області Росії.
Рішення про будівництво заводу в Україні ще не ухвалене.
Як відзначає експерт у питаннях військово-промислового комплексу
Сергій Згурець, перед цим варто узгодити ще низку питань.
Власне, виробником танків є консорціум Krauss-Maffei-Wegmann,
тобто структура, яка, власне, відповідає за виготовлення танку в цілому.
А Rheinmetall відповідає за башту і за нову гармату.
І, власне, ми розуміємо, що ініціатива Rheinmetall, вона є в тому,
аби розширити ринки збуту для своєї продукції.
Але коли ми говоримо про завод, то, я думаю, що треба знати
і позицію концерну Krauss-Maffei-Wegmann.
Член комітету з питань оборони німецького бундестагу Нільс Ґрюндер
в інтерв'ю DW пояснив, що для будівництва заводу не потрібно буде
погодження з німецьким урядом. Утім дозвіл ФРН знадобиться
для постачання вже готових танків - у тому числі Україні.
Водночас, за словами депутата, для самої Німеччини плюс угоди в тому,
що в довгостроковій перспективі не треба буде чіпати запаси Бундесверу:
Україну можна буде озброювати танками, виробленими в Україні.
Будівництво німецького заводу в Україні Ґрюндер підтримує і з політичних міркувань.
Незалежно від питання, чи взагалі буде побудований завод в Україні,
Німеччина має брати на себе більше в питанні архітектури безпеки Європи.
Німеччина має лідерські амбіції в Європі. І їх треба підкріпити діями.
Це спрацює, тільки якщо ми візьмемо на себе більшу відповідальність
за безпеку - самих себе та наших сусідів з ЄС.
Німеччині треба більше інвестувати у військову інфраструктуру,
досягти, нарешті, рівня військових витрат у 2 відсотки від ВВП.
Водночас постає питання безпеки майбутнього підприємства.
Хоча завод поки лише в проєкті, заступник голови Ради безпеки РФ Дмитро Медведєв
уже пригрозив відзначити початок його будівництва "салютом із Калібрів".
У самому Rheinmetall певні, що українська ППО зможе захистити завод.
Експерти також припускають, що підприємство можна було б розмістити
на заході України, в горах або під землею. Тоді як погрози Росії
фахівці не радять розцінювати як можливу ескалацію.
По-перше, ми вже бачили постійні негативні реакції Росії на дії Заходу у цій війні.
Поки що вони лишаються на словесному рівні.
Тому я не думаю, що й історія із заводом призведе до ескалації.
А по-друге, чи треба взагалі брати це до уваги? У довгостроковій перспективі
йдеться про деескалацію чи навіть закінчення війни.
Тож мені здається, що ми надто часто ставимо це питання
про "можливу ескалацію" з Росією.
В Україну вже постачаються німецькі "Леопарди", щоправда, з Польщі.
Експерти відзначають, що невдовзі ЗСУ цілком перейде
з радянських на західні танки.
На думку військового експерта Сергія Згурця, завод Rheinmetall
міг би стати дієвим кроком у цьому напрямку.
Експерт вважає, що ідеальний варіант для України - якщо Rheinmetall
скооперується з українськими розробниками зброї.
І не лише виготовлятиме танки "Пантера", які поки існує лише в демонстраційному екземплярі,
а й ремонтуватиме вже поставлені Україні "Леопарди".
Однак, за словами Сергія Згурця, Україні все це обійдеться недешево.
Зараз питання щодо вартості робочої сили, яке раніше вважалося
певною перевагою України чи пострадянського простору, вже не працює.
Зараз питання вартості танків, скоріш є інтегральним показником
від вартості комплектувальних елементів, які вже достатньо суттєво зросли.
І значною мірою зараз головний виклик, що головним ресурсом є не гроші,
зараз грошей для зброї в світі є багато. Немає часу для її виготовлення
і обмежені потужності для її виготовлення.
Питання часу - одне з ключових. Якщо рішення про будівництво
танкового заводу буде ухвалене, на його спорудження можуть
піти роки, зазначають експерти.
Турецька компанія "Байкар" понад рік тому заявила про плани
збудувати завод з виробництва дронів "Байрактар" в Україні.
Нині в компанії зазначають: на будівництво підприємства піде до двох років,
а протягом минулого року готувалася правова база.
Водночас, на думку експерта Сергія Згурця, турецькі й німецькі підприємці
- далеко не єдині, хто цікавиться Україною, а серед світових виробників зброї
вже почалася боротьба за український ринок.
Зразки озброєння, які надходять в українську армію
від закордонних виробників, проходять певний тест реальною війною,
і тому усі виробники розуміють, що це одна складова того, що треба,
щоб наша зброя була в Україні. А потім Україна буде повністю переоснащувати
свою армію тими зразками, які будуть найбільш оптимально підходити
до нових викликів війни. Тому що якщо Україна буде першим користувачем
цього танку "Пантер-51", то фактично потім, я думаю, що і сам Бундесвер
буде закуповувати цей зразок, розуміючи, наскільки він був ефективний
у бойових діях з реальною загрозою у вигляді російської танкової гармати.
Не виключено, що поки нові оборонні підприємство,
зокрема й танковий завод, запрацюють в Україні, війна вже закінчиться.
Але це не означає, що Україні не знадобиться зброя для захисту.